The Burj Al Arab is the most singular and luxurious hotel on earth.
While most posh hotels top out at five stars,...
...the Burj Al Arab actually managed to become the world's first seven-star hotel.
At 1,053 feet, it's one of the tallest hotels on the planet...
...and the iconic structure cost more than 1 billion dollars to build.
Located on a man-made island 280 meters off Jumeirah Beach,...
...Burj Al Arab was opened in 1999...
...and still dominates the city's skyline with its iconic silhouette.
Burj Al Arab offers the ultimate in luxury,...
...featuring a 180-meter-tall atrium, a fleet of white Rolls-Royce cars,...
...dancing fountains, and touches of gold leaf everywhere.
A single night can cost up to 24,000 dollars,...
...meaning that only the highest rollers are allowed through its exclusive doors.
Each of the hotel's 202 suites stands two floors high...
...and are decorated with elegantly styled furniture and carpet.
The beachfront hotel also runs an exotic aquarium...
...with a full team of marine biologists...
...to look after the well-being of the fish and sharks.
In case the hotel is too expensive but you still want to visit,...
...they offer two acclaimed restaurants.
Al Muntaha offers excellent views of Dubai...
...and sits 200 meters above the Persian Gulf...
...suspended by a full cantilever that is accessed in a panoramic elevator.
Al Mahara features a large saltwater aquarium...
...and offers entry via a unique simulated submarine voyage.
The hotel is perhaps most famous for its tennis court,...
...sitting a remarkable 650 feet above the ground.
In 2005, a grass helipad was converted into a 4,500-square-foot tennis court...
...so that Dubai could promote the upcoming Dubai Open tennis tournament.